was last time this place was properly
cleaned they're catching these guys
clean up every single night every single
night that's absolutely [__] are you
looking properly or are you just tipping
on a chef so maybe one knows you don't
need to be a chef to understand the
kitchen's [__] dirty
that there is every knife
that's every night
[__] sake
do you have any idea how quick this [__]
can ignite nope
how do we get wings like this
oh why the Brussels sprouts in with the
wings
no clue to be honest I think I've just
got shuffled around when we were running
around like chickens back here they're
cooked right they should be part cooked
but when you pop cook them and they're
still raw in the middle
that's the most dangerous time for a
chicken right the raw continues growing
in bacteria it affects the cook part
everything it touches just
cross-contaminating
it's fundamentally wrong
where's the main walking see this one
here yeah where is that smell coming
from
what is that smell oh my gosh
unbelievable
[Music]
where's that smell coming from
oh my God
what is that now
why is all this stuff set in that blood
it's also on one film a month old are
you telling me that for sure is a month
old like you know for sure probably can
you two [__] off the dining room a word
for curing
so I'm disgusting right now like no
different than you are right now I'm
completely beside myself this
everything you've got into this business
a walking like that you're losing
thousands of dollars and actually when
you really dig in there and you really
look at everything and I mean you know
where to look I'm not a restaurant
tourist so you know where to kind of
look at it you need to stop the excuses
you need to start looking within and you
need to start becoming accountable
that's clear today isn't it I want the
chefs in here I don't want this [__]
place cleaned
ah it's frustrating
first of all where's the kitchen this is
our kitchen
you haven't even got a stove we have a
burger
that's our stove
from 1974. what'd you do on that uh we
have a skillet up there to cook our taco
meat
and what is this contraption a really
shitty oven what is a toaster
so how did you cook the pizzas we run
them through from this end they go
through that in it takes about six to
eight minutes
this is it
when was the last time these were clean
probably two or three months two or
three months or two or three years
Steve talk to me
I can't see it
come on
there's a [__] pizza cooked in a
1980s toaster and things have just been
slipping our standards just keep this is
beyond slipping now
I'm Brad
is this how bruscus is run absolutely
not how do you function like this
at a low standard it looks like
oh my gosh [__] disgusting Stephen
step up here and look down there
it's lined with rat [__]
every rat in the air is dumped on top of
your [__] fridge oh [__]
disgusting not months not wigs years of
ratchet
for the love of God
what has happened to us
why are we standing here like pigs and
[__] festering [__] rat [__] my
worries you're not even drunk
at least if you were slightly Jones is a
[__] excuse
what's happened to us
why are we standing here like pigs and
[__] festering [__] rat [__]
my worries you're not even drunk
at least we were slightly Jones is a
[__] excuse
this is not our kitchen it's a hellhole
[Music]
do something you've never done roll up
your sleeves and get this [__] place
spotless
I got it
I wouldn't keep anything that's been in
that fridge there's rat [__] up there
now that these owners are realizing just
how big of a job this is
you got a bigger trash can I need one
I was watching behind the line I was
mortified to the practices
when was the last time this kitchen was
cleaned it ain't been clean since we've
been over what
it hasn't been cleaned in eight months I
only been in charge the last two months
oh my gosh
[Music]
fridge is not even on no none of this is
working properly we've got stuff in here
yes because I have nowhere else to store
it we can't put in a fridge it's not
working yeah but I'm not using it you
have to take some responsibility there
needs to be accountability here
somewhere that's moldy
what's in this one here
what is that
pulled pork
pull
thank you
[Music]
smell that I can smell it pause it to
the owner
oh come on
[Music]
three I don't stand in front of me you
have to be kidding me
what's that chicken strips
the strips in this yeah and what they
for we was cooking a sandwich for a
salad they fresh strips it's
sits in bloody water you're right this
is a [__] disaster what has happened
to us no help lack of hell you don't
need help yeah shut that [__] away no I
don't need help to throw that away but I
need help to keep this kitchen in order
you still need to take care of
everything break down put everything
away I had no idea this stuff is jammed
back there
well maybe if somebody come in the
kitchen and help Tasha out in the
kitchen then everybody know everything
about everything but when y'all leave it
all for one person to do and don't offer
a hand then this is what happened
somebody was last time you stood behind
the line I actually went through this at
night I haven't I don't know what I'm
doing and I don't know what needs to be
where oh come on you know [__] damn
well that's ridiculous that is
embarrassing that is ridiculous that
[__] there you're never gonna sell to
anybody
this is excuse after excuse after excuse
and you can't tell without [__] mold
you can't tell that that's rotten come
on Jermaine [__] off
this is excuse after excuse after excuse
and you can't tell that that's [__]
moles you can't tell that that's rotten
come on Jermaine [__] off
yeah I'm sympathetically got no one to
[__] run this place but I'm not
sympathetic to [__]
can I have a moment where Chef on my own
pleasing to go in the dining room I'm
[__] I don't know what to say anymore
can you go get them bring them
downstairs if the food I ate yesterday
is any indication I shudder to think of
the practices going on inside okay so
the minute you go inside a walk and it
gives you an indication how business is
functioning when was the last time you
cleaned this out last week last week wow
[__] it out man
smell in here
come on what is that
what is that it's a pork and when pork
sits in all that blood there
what happens to the pork sour
oh gosh oh no what the [__] is this
that will be your goulash and that stays
in there yep no Ladle and more
importantly no date
that was made the last Wednesday last
Wednesday
what does that do to food Cynthia it
spoils it it's rusty rusty dirty [__]
from a cremated pan come on
what the [__] is this
and that stays in there yep Rusty dirty
[__] from a cremated pan come on Mark
I'm at a loss for Workshop this is not
how you run the Phoenix no sir I know
we've hit hard times I get that but we
can't run this business like we're
giving up uh let's go upstairs to the
kitchen please my last and Joker I don't
care how busy
[Music]
you guys see that
Tim come over I know you look disgusted
is that the [__] I at lunchtime yes you
probably believe so oh my God
I just want some form of responsibility
somewhere
Cynthia can we get this place cleaned
yes Mark can I have a quick word
something you can get a cracking please
yes get started
[Music]
I think we should
first oh the salads salmon this is bad
as I thought it was Tim Dwayne and Dot
they need to take responsibility just
dump it just dump it I'm gonna get the
center out okay I've got tons to do down
Main Street I'll pop back later yeah
thank you excuse me oh boy everything
has to go in the trash feels good
getting rid of this stuff